Eric was the best screenplay that you've
ever read and was that script ever
turned into a movie mm-hmm that's a
tricky one the best screenplay I have
ever read that I have personally read I
would have to go back to Erin Brockovich
I would say I mean you know there's
hundreds of thousands of others out
there that I have not read but of the
ones that I have premeditatedly sat down
with and read more than once and made
notes about and so forth I would have to
say it was there in Brockovich and
that's why I use it the way I do in
class Susannah grant taught me a great
deal about screenwriting in that one
script but what was the other part of
the question oh well that was the script
turned into a film almost definitely
yeah it was definitely definitely done
so but you know there's something else
here if I might I
I encourage people and point them in the
direction of studying good movies the
screenplays of good movies but just as
valuable every bit as valuable and in
some cases more valuable is studying the
screenplays if you can get your hands on
them but certainly studying the movies
that bomb movies that are really bad
because they can teach you just as much
as the good stuff they can teach you
what not to do what doesn't work and the
idea to really get good at the craft is
to get build for yourself an analytical
eye and if you want to get good at
analysis look at some bet the movies you
hate I mean everybody comes Jenna what's
what's your worst favorite you know what
the worst movie I ever saw
oh my god oh no I said okay get that
movie and I want you to see it three
times and they freaked out I better go
spending time with that basic yeah you
know this kind of stuff and I say
I think this thing through if you really
hate it you have to know why just
telling me you hate it accomplishes
nothing you have learned nothing what
you have to learn is why do you hate it
what ways
in what ways has it let you down as a
creative undertaking nobody sets out to
write a bet and make a bad movie nobody
they may set out to be I will you know
will - this piece often it'll be in a
will get some money out of the market
yeah but they don't intend that it be a
bad movie movies go bad for a whole a
whole swath and stack of reasons and we
need to know why we need to know why I
was gonna I'm not gonna mention some
titles I was thinking about some titles
I don't want to go there but I've
learned an awful lot from screenplays
and movies that are not good why are
they not good learn that and then you're
growing as a screenwriter
you